[Musique]
un mixte demande non pas le
rétablissement à l'identique du texte
invalidé par le Conseil d'État mais il
souhaite que les opérations de
renaturation n'aggravant pas le risque
d'inondation n'impactant pas les moulins
ne représentant pas de danger pour la
sécurité publique et n'ayant aucune
incidence dans le domaine de la
production d'énergie il souhaite tout
simplement que ces opérations demeurent
soumises au régime de la déclaration
j'ajoute qu'il est essentiel pour les
collectivités de pouvoir bénéficier des
financements favorables mis en place par
les agences de l'eau pour des projets
très largement
publicités pardon par les élus les
populations et des associations de
défense de l'environnement en l'état le
maintien d'un tel arrêt et la
suppression du système déclaratif fera
de 2023 une année blanche en matière de
travaux de renaturation alors même que
leur financement est assuré et que de
nombreuses entreprises de travaux
publics attendent le lancement de ces
opérations alors Monsieur le Ministre
qu'entendez-vous faire pour que le bon
sens l'EMP